eu vim aqui hoje compartilhar um sonho
com vocês e quase como th de citar uma
frase achando que era do raulzito que
embalou a os meus 10 anos de idade mas
na verdade a fase é de cervantes que diz
precisar de uma cola quando se sonha
sozinho é apenas um sonho quando se
sonha junto é o começo da realidade
eu acho que isso é uma das coisas mais
legais que têm do universo colaborativa
que ele é cheio de opções e eu quero que
vocês se sintam investigados e
convidados a eventualmente embarcar
nesse sonho não só ele não tem novidade
é certa forma o título da fala é o local
mais inovador e sustentável da américa
latina e eu vou contar um pouco pra
vocês como é que a gente chegou nesse
ponto e como é que a gente imagina
construir isso e fazer isso efetivamente
acontecer tudo começou lá em 2012 era
uma época de crise no setor de
transportes
só se uma empresa que fabrica estações
de tratamento de água que recicla água
pra poder utilizar de novo nos processos
de lavagem dos veículos
e aí o mercado estava em crise ninguém
comprava ninguém vendia nada e reza a
lenda que a necessidade é a mãe da
criatividade e aí como alternativa para
sobreviver à crise a gente resolveu
dividir espaço na expectativa de pagar -
aluguel paga menos luz paga menos água e
de fato convidamos uma empresa pra vir
alice junto conosco 60 dias foi o que
precisou para descobrir que não se
tratava só de de conta em 60 dias a
gente descobriu que ele tinha muito mais
a compartilhar e complementar as
competências técnicas porque a gente
podia se valer 1 do conhecimento do
outro para oferecer o serviço e até mais
do que isso a gente podia se valer 1 da
rede de relacionamento do outro para
poder alcançar e oferecer outras
oportunidades além da rede
foi assim que descobriu que tinha uma
oportunidade que é muito além do que a
gente estava pensando inicialmente era
dividir custos ea gente escreveu esse
projeto chamado de paralelo vivo é uma
das casas colaborativa daqui de porto
alegre onde a gente começou conectar
cada vez mais
iniciativas empreendedores cientistas
pensadores que tivesse algum tipo de
produtos serviços tecnologia o
conhecimento voltado para a
sustentabilidade
nessa nossa dicéia de identificar esses
empreendedores e conectar esses
empreendedores têm um qi que eu gosto
muito que o thiago é um guri ele tem 20
e poucos anos ele chegou um dia lá no
paralelo disse cara quero quero
trabalhar aqui a fazer quarta empresa
não tenho com esta iniciativa não tenho
atleta idéia eu não tenho que pagar para
ficar aqui quero então vem né porque
sustentabilidade começa até com pagar as
contas né
assim thiago sentou lá ea gente vê um
boost ado com aquele guri que estava
sentado vai fazer o quê
e ele pra mim ele representa é o que ele
é o que é e se ele começou a pescar um
pouco do conhecimento de cada um das
meninas que trabalhava com arquitetura
do pessoal que trabalhava com água do
pessoal que trabalha com materiais e ele
fundou a primeira startup que nasceu lá
dentro que tinha como proposta
desenvolver jardins urbanos para
resolver parte daqui a pouco um problema
de alimentação tudo automatizado
a idéia genial estamos bem empolgados
montaram tudo que precisa para montar e
tão rápido quanto ele teve essa idéia a
idéia não prosperou três quatro meses
depois ele tinha errado em algumas
formalidades
ele errou no modelo de negócio é
relativamente caro vender o que estava
querendo vender mas é o que é isso né
e ele não desistiu persistiu continua
ali se provocando provocando os outros
fazendo novas relações novas conexões e
de lá ele criou um segundo negócio com
outros sócios muito mais maduro ele
tinha que ter aprendido alguma coisa na
trajetória dele né
e ele fundou uma nova empresa que hoje
cuida de resíduos orgânicos da cidade de
porto alegre
ele deve estar sempre uns três ou quatro
meses e hoje ele já tem aproximadamente
80 famílias e o mais legal é que eles
têm uma fila de espera de mais ou menos
umas 700 e 800 pessoas estão abrindo
operação no litoral estão crescendo
muito
ah e não para o anel tiago continua
fazendo outras parcerias e outras com
relações com os pares do paralelo e até
mesmo fora do paralelo ele tem hoje
inúmeros projetos que envolvem toda essa
nossa comunidade mas foi um dia olhando
isso e essa essa riqueza dos
relacionamentos que surgiram dali que
agentes instigou olhar pra rede
e foi o que a gente resolveu chamar
então de um algoritmo vivo que é essa
potencialidade das conexões que
acontecem e que provocam e que isso que
provoca isso vira gay novas iniciativas
novas ideias novos negócios
a gente chamou de algoritmo vivo que a
gente entende que é quase como uma linha
não programável nem a gente sabe mais ou
menos como ele funciona não tem como
replicadores a mistura tudo e as coisas
vão simplesmente acontecendo só precisa
de gente boa gente que passa a escolha
de querer participar
o curioso do do algoritmo vida que um
dia não se sente já estava ciente disso
ou não mas um dia cruzou pelo paralelo o
professor marco vasques do ma mg e
internacional chamada global urban
development que auxilia cidades a
desenvolverem de forma mais sustentável
econômica e sustentável
ele chegou lá e disse pra gente pai eu
nunca vi um espaço colaborativo que
trabalha com esse propósito de inovação
e sustentabilidade muito legal e tal e
aí o mar começou a conviver nesse nosso
ecossistema e eu acho que talvez muito
por conta de seu algoritmo vivo que
ninguém sabe como funciona
ele teve uma ideia de criar e aí o sonho
que eu vim dividir com vocês hoje aqui
criar um local mais inovador e
sustentável da américa latina
é pra isso a gente desenvolver o projeto
da zona de inovação e sustentabilidade
que fica entre o 4º distrito bairro
floresta e que especificamente a zona
teria como objetivo ser um local mais
inovador e sustentável do rio grande do
sul para que isso inspirasse outras
comunidades a seguir o mesmo caminho
a idéia é trabalhar com mobilidade
urbana energias renováveis consumo é
inteligente de energias mas também o
relacionamento com lixo até o
relacionamento com os
a ea gente entende que quando começou a
surgir a zona e isso de certa forma foi
potencializando porque aumentou os
nossos limites de relacionamento e esses
essas potencialidades das relações que a
gente fazia surgiu o que é para nós hoje
a maior chance de mudar a fotografia da
cidade de concreto tem muito pouco né
tem a ideia que existe neto aqui
dividindo talvez um pouco mais real hoje
e tem um protocolo de intenções assinado
com o principal responsável por ajudar a
fazer isso acontecer que é o que o
shopping total de construir na esquina
da rua mais bonita do mundo
o primeiro parque temático de inovação
sustentabilidade e megalomaníaco não é o
nosso problema aqui né pessoal tão tudo
o que a gente pensa é pra sempre a
história então a idéia é montar um
parque que virasse um presente para a
cidade
então hoje é uma área que está sendo
ocupada a gente queria permitir que o
cidadão pudesse utilizar aquela área
para fazer e eventos para ter lazer para
fazer o que eles quiserem fazer mas
também utilizar para hospedar esse tipo
de iniciativa e essas relações que a
gente está a fim de promover a ea idéia
é que o shopping trabalho de fato junto
com o shopping e eventualmente criando
novas formas de consumo ou de relação de
consumo mas também ou até mesmo a gestão
de resíduos do shopping mas também com a
rua mais bonita do mundo né assim sendo
não sendo concordando não concordando só
tá lá é um ativo da cidade sucateado não
tem uma placa na cidade o ônibus tudo
passar reto pela rua não para lia não
tem uma iluminação decente uma rua
relativamente perigosa
então a gente cria certa forma se
apropriar disso se poderá disso nós
cidadãos para fazer de fato valorizar
salvou como um ativo turístico
eu moro perto da rua helvétia todo final
de semana a gente batendo foto lá que
vêm lados não seja a última não são os
meus vizinhos que vão bater foto ali né
mas eu acho que a gente conseguia fazer
de fato um um local mais inovador e
sustentável
não é só a gente fazer um um escolheu
uma zona e incentivar iniciativas e
daqui a pouco montar um parque para isso
a gente pensou duas tecnologias sociais
nem sei se é uma tecnologia social é
assim que a gente tem chamado é assim
que a gente consegue assim que a gente
se engaje na primeira delas a gente
chama de laboratório de p d e pro das
cidades inteligentes desenvolvimento
sustentável academia fala já em pdf pdi
na pesquisa desenvolvimento e inovação
em ti inventou esse termo novo pesquisa
desenvolvimento e inovação e
prototipação que não basta pensar a
idéia de botar as idéias na prática
e aí como uma forma de a gente fazer
isso acontecer antibola um esqueminha
gráfico que seria a gente quer achar as
pessoas que queiram eventualmente
resolver esses problemas sociais
conectar elano conectar elas esse
algoritmo a gente entende que deve ter
alguma coisa que possa facilitar e fazer
essas pessoas transformar esses
problemas em idéias
essas idéias seria um mentor adas por
instituições como sebrae finep por todos
os profissionais que a gente conhece
dessa rede colaborativa ou profissionais
de mercado mesmo assim como a própria
academia né conhecimento técnico
científico para que essas idéias
amadurecerem tem a oportunidade de ser
aceleradas e aí a gente tem duas chances
o agente acelera uma ideia que é um
sucesso ea gente vai estar exportando
soluções para cidades inteligentes para
novo hamburgo caxias xangai buenos aires
pouco importa ou essas idéias não dá
errado e vai ter oportunidade de
reciclar isso e botar esse cara de novo
incubadora e transformar isso num
aprendizado e reciclar essa idéia
você não vai fora nada de fora na pele
pode ser essa idéia realmente tive aqui
fora porque às vezes acontece né
esse cara vai ter que virar um mentor
ele tem uma trajetória uma curva de
aprendizado que ele tem que dividir com
os outros a gente inventou isso com um
objetivo que é minerar empreendedores
que resolvam problemas da cidade
outros objetivos o desenvolvimento
sustentável
nós queremos minerar empreendedores que
resolvam problemas para tentar encontrar
o que seria o primeiro unicórnio social
brasileiro
todo mundo sabe que o unicórnio com
certeza não essa representação gráfica
que o nosso design maravilhoso conseguiu
inventar para nós
a unicoba na linguagem dos negócios só
aquelas empresas que têm uma avaliação
de mercado de 1 bilhão de reais
de dólares mas a gente já deu essa
adaptada aqui independente da da taxa do
da dodô monetário
então o que a gente quer fazer isso a
gente quer achar os empreendedores
aqueles empreendedores que podem ter uma
idéia com potencial de valer 1 bilhão de
reais
azar que não ache qualquer coisa que ele
te encontrar no caminho daquele processo
de protecção que gere negócios de valor
social nos interessa mas já que a gente
já tá aqui né falando de unicórnio
estava entendendo que estava faltando um
pedacinho para de fato ser um local
inovador e aí da mesma maneira que a
gente pensou em me ver a empreendedores
que resolvam problemas
a gente pensou em me liberar
pesquisadores que investiguem esses
problemas
nós fazemos parte da economia
colaborativa economia criativa economia
circular a economia compartilhada é a
uma infinidade de economia dessas novas
relações que ninguém sabe direito como
funciona e um campo fértil para tentar
investigar e cavocar tudo que tivesse
conhecimento aí e aproveitar que somos
todos os objetos desse tipo de pesquisa
e tentar conectar esses pesquisadores
via algoritmo vivo via qualquer outra
coisa que a gente entenda que possa
canalizar esse tipo de relação para
tentar e essa é a parte mais difícil que
eu dizer que até me acostumar diz essa
frase aqui é é complicada porque é
relativamente pretensiosa mas é possível
né
a gente tem que se inspirar nos vizinhos
não precisa pensar nos estados unidos na
frança dá pra pensar na argentina que
tem dá pra pensar
o chile que tem dá pra pensar no
paraguai que tem a pensar dos países que
desenvolvem pesquisas que de fato então
aí para investigar e propor novas idéias
então do mesmo jeito que ele está
querendo trazer e achar um unicórnio
aqui para tentar trazer esse exemplo por
que não daria pra gente tentar achar
esse pesquisador que investiga o
problema é que toca no estado da arte do
conhecimento que eventualmente não possa
trazer o primeiro prémio nobel
brasileira ataque o convite para a gente
sonhar com isso junto
tem um sonho tem delírio e tem
alucinações
são hoje um pouco importa que eu só acho
que se a gente começar a dividir isso e
compartilhar
já metade do caminho muito obrigado
[Aplausos]